[Music]
our first animal tonight it looks like
you just brought a kitten yeah well I
did she is a kitten this is an Asian
Leopard Cat kitten that's a leopard cat
it's a leper cat not a leopard it's a
small cat species that obviously lives
in Asia right and so you can pet her
I can pattern yeah she's only about
eight weeks old let's say we get her Oh
but his cuter mind if I hold that okay
yeah she's got sharp claws so you want
to be careful oh shoot I just tie me as
you hand her to me she is still a wild
animal so you don't want to have one of
these guys as a pet if you well how
about for a little while no not really
just for like four years now
trust me this this species won't use a
litter box so in captivity at the zoo's
where these guys live they have to go
they like to go and sinks right because
they like to go to the bathroom and
water in the wild Andy does that yeah so
if you want if you want to get more just
because of fun yeah if you want if you
want to cat that dumb goes to the
bathroom and your sink by all means but
I love the sound is that's that's gonna
be a lie cute roar yeah it is it well
again when this cat gets to be
full-grown you can rip your face off
so why do you seem to revel in that
imagery you know this cat will never
harm me because this cat knows I fed it
on television well that that does go a
long way what a sweetie pie but you know
that's why I bring these animals on the
show at National Wildlife Federation we
need everybody's help to I'll protect
these animals in the wild these guys are
hunted for their fur so we want to make
sure that you know we conserve wildlife
and we need everybody's help to do that
all right yeah and what's in the bottle
it's just that its formula so I'm kind
of for me that you would feed the
domestic kitten so yeah I thought it was
a rum drink yeah all right let's move on
to the next animal what a great animal
though I love to that's the Asian
Leopard Cat so this one favorite animals
oh my God look at this not as exotic as
the Asian Leopard Cat but something that
a lot of people are probably familiar
with this is a nine banded armadillo and
if you counted those bands they're
probably more than nine they can have as
many as 11 right and the turn around
this soil what how do they get extra
bands is it like the Cub Scouts where
you move your way up the ladder
how does it work it's as they get older
and the bands basically allow them to
kind of kind of curl up a little bit
this species of Armadillo yeah he looks
very right now everything about this
armadillo is like I'll go on this show
but I'm not gonna like it now these guys
you know mostly mostly people see them
on the side of the road oh these are the
ones that people run over yeah
unfortunately they're not very savvy
with roads and if you are from the South
you know that the saying goes that
armadillos are born on the side of the
road because that's usually where you
see them but they do end up getting run
over by cars a lot and again with
wildlife you want to make sure that
we're giving it a break and pay
attention when you're driving out there
so that you don't run them all over yeah
okay I just want you to feel the same
their job to stay out of the road yeah I
mean go ahead sorry did I say something
it offends though I didn't feel that
this protects that animal from predators
like coyotes or even you know big cats
like mountain lions will have a hard
time getting through that and of course
this is the only other species out there
that can get leprosy and so sometimes it
does
you don't have to worry this guy does
not have leprosy I promise you know it's
the timing of your information it's
really the great part here watch I'll
look that all up seola proceed cat